hello everybody it is uh seven o'clock
you're watching the breakfast show here
on sky news two weeks since president
putin invaded ukraine and the war has
seen possibly its most significant
atrocity yet a maternity hospital in
mario poll bombed by russian forces
speaking to sky news ukraine's president
zelinski reiterated his call for a
no-fly zone over the country we'll speak
to the armed forces minister james
heapey and labour's ed miliband this
morning it's thursday the 10th of march
beyond atrocity ukraine's president says
children are buried under the rubble of
a hospital bombed in mariopol as he
again urges the west to impose a no-fly
zone over the country
he tells sky news the world must act now
before it's too late and stop the
bombing
if it's prolonged
this way yes you will see
they will close the sky
but will lose millions of people
the ukrainian government says that more
than a thousand people have been killed
in mario paul since russia's invasion
began
there were more airstrikes overnight
local officials say two more hospitals
were hit 90 miles west of kiev
and this is the scene live in antalya in
turkey ahead of the highest level talks
so far to take place during the conflict
with the ukrainian foreign minister
meeting his russian counterpart this
morning
also ahead on the program for you
we'll speak to the exiled belarusian
opposition leader who says belarus
military is under kremlin control
and we'll speak to the animal rescue
charity in ukraine which is also helping
to deliver supplies to hospitals
[Music]
hello everybody ukraine's president has
told sky news that millions of people
could die if the world does not stop the
bombing of his country in an exclusive
interview for british television he
accused western countries of being
indecisive but britain and the united
states have consistently rejected
ukraine's plea for a no-fly zone these
are the latest developments the ukraine
at the uk's ministry of defense says
there's been a notable decrease in
russian military air activity in recent
days due to the unexpected effectiveness
of ukraine's defence
three hospitals have been hit by russian
airstrikes two overnight and one
yesterday on a maternity hospital in
mariopol russia has dismissed the mario
paul attack as fake news
ukraine says 35 000 civilians have fled
through humanitarian corridors so far
mainly in the city of sumi in the east
more evacuations are expected today
and as talks between ukrainian and
russian foreign ministers are scheduled
to take place in turkey today president
zielenski has said ukraine alone cannot
end the war he was speaking to our
special correspondent alex crawford in
kiev
they want us to feel like animals
because they blocked our cities the
biggest cities in ukraine and they
blocked and and because they don't want
our our people to get some food water
yesterday for example children i don't
know if you if you know the children in
mariopol was uh the child was dead
yes you know that that is the idea of
of this operation or or i don't know how
house putin's
telling about it so that the idea
to you
you do do with ukrainians animals
but but we are not
so how do you stop it are you going are
you prepared to do a deal you've said
you're happy to talk we can't stop
alone
all this
no it's it's it's
only if the world will unite
around ukraine
iran or uniting around ukraine they're
not they're still it's still very slowly
it's still very slowly but you can feel
it only when you are here because the
people from europe or usa
it's far from ukraine it's far from the
heart of this tragedy and and you you
can't see you you can't understand the
details because you are not fighting
here and i understand why and i don't
want them to fight
but these countries can help can unite
because we can't speak about the close
the
i'm sorry that i'm speaking again and
again about this problem but we spoke
about children hospitals etc and you
know the the the the
number of this child that's and and
and
so
we are speaking about closing the sky
you can't decide
to close or not to close
you can't decide if you are united
against the nazism and this terror
you have to close
not me don't wait me asking you several
times a lot million times close the sky
no you have to phone us to our people
who lost their children and say sorry we
didn't do it yesterday one week ago we
didn't
push
putin we didn't speak with him a lot we
didn't found
find the dialogue with him we we we did
nothing and it's true yesterday
the world did nothing i'm sorry but it's
true
the british prime minister as a number
of other
world leaders say if they do that if
they close the sky that is that could
exacerbate and make the situation even
worse if they provide if they allow
poland to provide you jets on and
station it on nato land that will make
it worse what would you do
so the first question is rhetoric
and we we don't need rhetoric questions
and answers we have to have contracted
things so it would be worth for whom
for our families no
for whom
for them
no who knows nobody knows
and but we know exactly that now is very
bad
and in future it will be too late
and believe me
believe me if if it's prolonged
this way yes you will see
they will close the sky
but will lose millions of people
more from alex shortly but footage of
more airstrikes has emerged overnight
[Music]
local officials say two hospitals were
hit in sotomayor
that's 90 miles west of kiev a russian
aircraft was filmed flying overhead
shortly before the explosion the city's
mayor said windows were blown out of the
buildings but no one was injured
speak to the armed forces minister
should be james heaping mr heapey thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning
how are we going to deal with this
monster who bombs um mothers and babies
well look okay
that is
um there is a simple answer to that
which is that he needs to stop i mean
for all of the debate that we have over
what the west should or shouldn't do one
man decides to fly his planes over
another country and drop bombs one man
decides to launch artillery and missiles
indiscriminately at urban areas
including as we've seen yesterday
hitting a hospital in which women are
giving birth um he needs to stop
uh could it have been an accident um
russia this morning saying that it's
fake news
well if if it was an accident and i'm
not sure that it will have been
then they need to be asking themselves
some pretty serious questions about
their tactics because the fact is that
they are launching artillery and
missiles into urban areas where they
know
that targeting is challenging and they
are using weapon systems that are not
precision
that is a policy choice that they've
made and the west is watching and
russian commanders need to remember that
war crimes are not just committed by
those at the very top of the russian
government they are committed all the
way down the chain of command by all who
are involved and these atrocities are
being watched they're being catalogued
and people will be held to account does
britain want this uh latest incident in
mario paul to be investigated as a war
crime
yes absolutely there's i mean it is
what you see on your tv screens
is a war crime now clearly there is
evidence to be gathered in which to
prove that it is a war crime and western
countries are working together to make
sure that that evidence is gathered in
the best way so that people can be held
to account but let's be clear what putin
is doing is not a war wage between two
militaries right now he has besieged the
number of ukrainian cities and he's
waged a war against ukrainian civilians
at what point will it be right for the
uk and or other nato countries to
intervene to prevent further war crimes
well this isn't being done as nato but
lots of countries have effectively made
a contribution that will allow the
ukrainians to defend themselves better
and with some success so in the first
wave of military aid that the
international community sent uh there
were from the uk's perspective anti-tank
weapons we've now sent
3615 of those uh and there's more to
come and they have been as you've seen
in your footage of burnt out russian
armored columns they've been
devastatingly effective other parts
international communities sent things
called stinger
missiles now they are kind of
entry-level anti-aircraft missiles but
they've been very successful the
ukrainian government claimed that 48
helicopters and 44 combat aircraft have
been shot down and so successful have
those stingers been that they've forced
the russians to fly their combat
missions at night
and whilst i can't verify the footage
you showed
earlier on that was a nighttime mission
so the next step is to provide the
ukrainians with an anti-aircraft
capability that works at night
and as the home as the defense secretary
announced the house of commons yesterday
we are looking at a capability called
the high velocity missile uh which we
hope will be able to achieve that and
we're just looking at the practicalities
and feasibility of how we would deploy
that uh to the ukrainians okay rest
assured minister we only uh show footage
on this channel that has been
independently verified um of course i'm
sorry i know you're very good at doing
that thank you um we know that the
ukrainians and uh the russians are
meeting in turkey to try to uh come up
with some sort of deal isn't now the
time for compromise is now the time for
us to speak to our ukrainian colleagues
and and urge them to come to some sort
of compromise with russia
but what compromise would you suggest is
acceptable i mean you know
four weeks ago ukraine was a sovereign
country living peacefully without
threatening its neighbors within its own
borders
i don't know that the international
community should be turning around to
president zlensky and say
it's time to reward putin
with uh having basically bullied him out
of the donbass
and to write off the crimea um if
president zlensky were to choose to do
that as the sovereign leader of ukraine
that's the decision for him but i think
he's made very clear he's unwilling to
accept that and i don't know that the
international community should be
willing to trade away ukrainian
sovereignty uh as part of any
negotiation
hundred military personnel are going to
poland to help with the visa
applications how many are going to cali
um will you forgive me that i think your
gallery might still be coming through on
in front of on the speaker could you ask
me your question again k please i can
i'm sorry about that um 100 military
personnel are going to poland how many
are going to cali
um they're we're not sending any to
calais at the moment uh having had a
conversation with a home office
forgive me we've still got the gallery
coming through quite loudly
can you hear me okay
i can i'm i'm sorry about the technical
issues is it fixed now i'll push on so
we we're not sending any to kelly i met
with the immigration minister yesterday
and i think their feeling is that the uh
the visa application centers in northern
france uh are
centers that they can reinforce um
themselves uh what they have asked us to
do is to supply manpower into uh poland
uh which is uh the busiest of the visa
application centers by some margin uh
and so we're just in the process of
making that happen uh and we will help
out in any way we can because i think
you know there's there's effectively two
sides to the uh to what can be done to
bring refugees here more quickly there's
a policy choice around the checks that
uh that we go through
but equally you can increase the
capacity of the pipeline to process more
people more quickly
the mod has made it made the offer to
the home office that we will
lean in to help them with that they've
accepted that offer will supply as many
people as they need in order to be able
to get the highest number of people
processed in the quickest time possible
and then the home secretary has got some
choices which i know she's considering
around how to further change the visa
process and what checks might be
necessary within it because i've been
looking at the visa application process
mr hippian for the benefit i know that
you'll know what it is but for the
benefit of our viewers
people need to create an account they
need to upload proof of qualifying
family in britain they need to upload
proof of ukraine residency before the
1st of january they need to provide
evidence that they're related to family
in britain or explain why they can't
they need to translate the documents
into english they need to book and
attend an appointment at a center in
poland hungary romania moldova or france
to take biometrics they need a tb
vaccination certificate waived but
applicants are mistakenly being asked
for one anyway and these are people that
are fleeing from war
surely we need to do something about
that
well and i think the home secretary is
very much keeping it under review there
is a um it is a hard job to be home
secretary you know you have to balance
uh on the one hand
to the united kingdom and i accept that
people will look at these tv screens and
say that there is an immediate uh
imperative to
uh to wave all this stuff and do it
quicker i know
that she is looking very very carefully
at what bits of policy could reasonably
be changed in order to do that but as i
said there is another way of increasing
the speed at which this is done and
that's the bit that we're involved in uh
we will make sure uh through working
with our colleagues at uk visa
immigration and home office ministers
that
we are providing uh staffing to visa
application centers
around the border of ukraine so that
they have higher capacity and are able
to deal with applications more quickly
which i think you know irrespective of
what policy changes may or may not come
that will make things much better for
those who are leaving ukraine and wants
to come to the united kingdom what's
going to happen to military personnel
who have deserted their post to go to
fight in ukraine
they'll be in an awful lot of trouble
well what is that i mean well they have
they have to be clear and the army has
put out a statement overnight um to
to say this it is illegal for a british
service person to
uh or first of all to go absent without
leave in the first place but to go
absent without leave in order to fight
in a foreign war is simply unacceptable
and frankly
risks the united kingdom um being
you know uh
wrongly claimed by russia to be a
belligerent in this and i think you know
service people who might think that they
are
doing the right thing should reflect
that it is 100 not the correct thing to
be doing and i'd go further and say it's
not just that small very that very small
number of soldiers that have gone awol
um apparently in order to go and fight
in ukraine i would say to the wider
veterans community i know because i have
stood
in the room where you do your
attestation and you accept the unlimited
liability in the service of your country
to stand up for what's right in the
world
that there's a thing deep inside you as
a soldier that makes you see tv images
like the ones you're showing and makes
you want to go and fight to put things
right
but no good comes from british service
people or veterans
going to ukraine to be a part of this
the ukrainians have got a huge amount of
uh manpower than their army ukrainian
nation has rallied to take up arms the
role that the west is playing is to
provide them with the best weaponry that
we can so that they can achieve their
aims and we are supporting every way we
can this is not the time for people to
be going there and more importantly kay
as the ukrainians have made clear once
you cross the border with the with the
expectation to fight you're in it for
good so people who think they can go
there do a couple of weeks take some
selfies get some instagram shots and
then come home that is not the way the
ukrainians are viewing the people that
go to fight for them british people
should not be doing it okay minister we
must let you go thank you for taking the
time to join us sorry about the
technical issues earlier thank you no
problem at all thank you thank you
well the bombing of the mario paul
hospital is pictured on many of the
front pages of the newspapers this
morning putin bombs children's hospital
is the headline for the eye newspaper
the metro describes it as a new low for
putin with a picture of some of those
that were injured the mirror says simply
barbaric while the male calls it
depraved and says boris johnson has
vowed to hold president putin to account
we saw the report from alex didn't we a
little bit earlier on she joins us now
live from kiev british exclusive
interview with the ukrainian president
um uh hi alex talk to me about how he
was how he seemed a man that is under an
awful lot of pressure trying um every
day to fight for his own citizens
well he's
doing an incredible
energy job if you like i mean i thought
he he was filled with energy despite
everything he certainly
looked a little bit tired that wouldn't
be surprising if he was he also sounded
tired his his voice was very gravelly uh
he's in a twilight zone because
everything's very dimly lit because
they've got a really big security issue
there i mean he's probably the most
wanted man on the russian hit list right
now so everything was very um difficult
in terms of you know we had to get in in
a secure way we're not allowed to
film anything we didn't they didn't want
us give away any positions even within
the president's office so
um they're very very
hot on that uh they didn't want to stay
in one place for very long after our
interview he was immediately whisked
away but he was angry angry and
frustrated at the rest of the world's
reactions he keeps on calling on the
rest of the world to the unite and when
i said well they are uniting aren't they
in terms of economic sanctions president
putin has seen that as a declaration of
of economic war if you like against
russia and he said he was very clear i
thought and remember this is a man who
feels his english is not that good he i
had to really press him to talk in
english and he was so determined and so
um driven to get his message across to
the english-speaking world that he he
pressed on in english and he said no
they're taking they're taking too long
we can't wait for multiple
governments to take decisions and
multiple world leaders to decide it's
the right thing he said i mentioned some
time ago to a number of world leaders
who we wouldn't name about how they
needed to cut nordstrom 2 and they
didn't until
everything started happening you
mentioned the casualties and the
civilian targets and all that and they
didn't take action so he very much
seemed to me to be saying that
blood was on the hands of a number of
world leaders for not taking action much
much sooner and every day every hour
that goes by
ukrainian
civilians and ukrainian soldiers are
being hurt and killed mario paul had
just happened as we went in to interview
him and i managed to catch him again on
the way out
to press him on what he thought should
happen to those who were targeting
hospitals and civilians particularly
this maternity hospital here's what he
had to say
all of them will be in prison that's
that's it what to see i don't want to
see how they how people cut their legs
or hands we have people we are normal
people they have to be in the prison and
stop bombing that's it what we want
him very much making clear that he wants
to see all these people particularly
president putin prosecuted for he
considers to be war crimes kay
okay alex thanks very much indeed
fascinating interview with the president
uh yesterday thanks for for securing
that for us thank you
speak to you in the next hour
and uh beth rigby will be speaking to
the prime minister this evening on sky
news on beth rigby interviews tonight at
9pm so watch out for that it's a new
programme uh fronted by beth starts this
evening very much looking forward to
that
still to come on the program before
you're going to be talking to labour's
ed miliband about the war in ukraine and
the impact on fuel prices as labour
announces their plan for energy security
later on joined by a lawyer working to
provide financial aid to ukrainian
refugees as they struggle to bypass uk
visa requirements
and the uk's former permanent
representative to nato lord ricketts
joining us to discuss the russia
invasion of ukraine and the role of the
west in the conflict
[Music]
and looking at the closer developments
for you now in a little bit more detail
here we go ukraine says 35 000 people
have so far been evacuated along safe
routes from besieged towns and cities
the governor of sumi in the northwest
has said evacuees are leaving this
morning after another ceasefire was
agreed
several hundred people fled open on the
outskirts of kiev making the journey out
along a makeshift wooden bridge
seventeen people were injured in an
attack on a maternity hospital in
mariopol casualties in the city are
being buried in a mass grave because
morgues
are full
another two hospitals were hit in zlatan
which is at 90 miles west of kiev the
city's mayor says nobody was injured
in the second city of kharkiv at least
four people were killed and 15 wounded
when a police headquarters was destroyed
and the un's nuclear watchdog has said
it has lost contact with monitoring
systems at the chernobyl and zaparazia
power plants both are under
russian control
goodness i'm not sure about my
pronunciations on some of those forgive
me this morning if you would uh many
ukrainians living abroad have been
returning home to help with the
country's war effort against russia nick
martin has been with uh some of those
making the journey and joins us now from
lev in western ukraine hi nick good
morning to you tell us more
well good morning kate as we've seen
millions of people have been fleeing
ukraine into neighboring countries a
million so far have fled into poland and
usually those trains
leaving ukraine have been absolutely
full of people trying to get out but
yesterday we saw a lot of people getting
onto trains into uk into the ukraine and
when we spent time on those trains it
was interesting to hear from people the
reasons why one woman i spoke to was a
teacher and a painter she was heading to
odessa which of course is in the sights
of vladimir putin she said she's not
scared of putin not scared of russia or
anyone else
and also spoke to a mother who has been
cut off from her husband and
six-year-old boy who are about 800 miles
away from where we are in la viv and she
said she'd love to try to get to them
but it's too dangerous so she's crossing
the border anyway to try and help with
that war effort of course more broadly
the russian military continue to
intensify
sieges over key ukrainian cities of
course we saw that horrendous attack on
the children's hospital maternity
hospital
in the port city of mariopol
people reported the ground shaking
and pregnant women being wheeled out and
children being trapped under the rubble
the white house have described that
attack as barbaric and today the world
health organization
confirmed that it appears that the
russian military have targeted no less
than 18 medical facilities
the russian military the russian
government say that they are only trying
to crush the ukrainian military but as
day by day goes on it is hard to see how
that can be the case with more and more
it appears civilian targets civilians
being uh targeted the russian invasion
of course continues and the amount of
people who are fleeing continues
yesterday we were reporting around two
million are set to leave this country
but of course it will be many many more
than that okay thanks thanks a lot
well the ukrainian and russian foreign
ministers are meeting in turkey today in
the highest level talks between the two
nations since the invasion began uh our
international affairs editor dominick
wagon joining us now uh from where the
meeting is taking place hi dominic good
morning what's hoped for
okay well the hope is that they can
somehow make some progress in the
diplomatic track that has been begun in
belarus and now as you say the highest
level meeting between the foreign
minister sergey lavrov and dimitro
calabro they hope they can build on that
talk to western diplomats so they they
say they don't have high hopes for the
dramatic process at the moment and i
think because of what's been happening
overnight and the last few days where it
seems the russians are now striking
hospitals i think those hopes are even
uh less encouraging if you like um the
prospects of a breakthrough here are
pretty limited i think what we're seeing
the russians doing in ukraine is what
they did in syria and homes to a level
of cynical perfection which is where
they use ceasefires and the aim is to
produce a ceasefire out of this meeting
as kind of tactics tactic of war it
allows a humanitarian corridor so that
allows a way out of an area and then the
russian air force in syria just
bombarded and use airstrikes to hit
hospitals and the reason for that is if
you can imagine at home your hospital
your maternity hospital is hit by an air
strike then you want to get out of the
area the safest place in your town has
been hit you need to flee and the
russian tactic in syria was to make
people flee in their thousands their
tens of thousands along these
humanitarian corridors under ceasefire
while they bombed these hospitals and
what the russians are seeing in places
like hurston is a lot of people coming
out on the streets confronting their
soldiers using people power trying to
confront tanks now one way of dealing
with that is you just force the
civilians to flee to to run for cover
and get out of the area and therefore
the fear is i think that's what they are
now trying to do in ukraine as they did
in syria so i think that is probably
going to be tempering any hopes any
optimism about these talks but it is a
good sign the talks are happening of
course so lavrov and caleb are meeting
for an hour and a half uh in an hour in
about half an hour's time holding press
conferences afterwards we'll see what
they have to say i think the best hope
is for some kind of a ceasefire the fear
is that the russia will then be using
that cynically as a kind of tactic of
war the turks say they want these talks
to then lead to leaders the two leaders
meeting we'll have to see if that leads
to anywhere but there is as you can see
a huge amount of interest a lot of press
here hoping uh against hope really that
there is some kind of breakthrough that
can be brought about in these talks here
in antalya and turkey
okay um dominic for now thank you thanks
a lot
looking at some of the stories in this
morning's newspapers and uh something
that no mom should ever have to
contemplate in the telegraph a pregnant
woman leaves the besieged maternity
hospital in the port city of marriott
in the times now in this image of
vladimir putin meeting with his
children's right commissioner in moscow
at the same time as the shelling of that
hospital
but some ukrainians are stilling still
trying to boost morale a member of the
kiev classic symphony orchestra pictured
here in the eye performing in the
capital
and this aid worker dressed as a clown
at a refugee center in the city of
denipro and finally in the mail
we see tamara who was married
who managed to celebrate i should say
her 87th birthday despite shielding from
overhead fire in her basement
looking at our top stories for you this
morning uh president zielinski has
accused the west of being indecisive and
tell sky news millions of people will
die if the world does not stop russia
bombing of ukraine
he's described the russia airstrike on a
maternity hospital in mario paul as a
war crime he says children are buried
beneath the rubble
[Music]
the russian and ukrainian foreign
ministers will meet today in turkey in
the highest level diplomatic talks so
far
what you're seeing on your tv screens is
a war crime that was the message from
the armed forces minister james heapey
just a moment ago on this programme i
asked him about the recent reports of
the mario paul maternity hospital being
bombed by russian forces this is what he
said
the west is watching and russian
commanders need to remember that war
crimes are not just committed by those
at the very top of the russian
government they are committed all the
way down the chain of command by all who
are involved what you see on your tv
screens
is a war crime now clearly there is
evidence to be gathered in which to
prove that it is a war crime and western
countries are working together to make
sure that that evidence is gathered in
the best way so that people can be held
to account but let's be clear what putin
is doing
is not a war wage between two militaries
right now he has besieged a number of
ukrainian cities and he's waged a war
against ukrainian civilians
uh tamara is here fascinating listening
to the minister this morning on all
sorts of levels not least um the selling
veterans and those going awol not to do
it absolutely in a complete rebuke to
what liz trust the foreign secretary
said in an interview a couple of weeks
ago which is that she would support
those going to fight for ukraine james
heapey was very clear that not just
serving soldiers must not desert their
posts as we know a very small number
have done and gone to ukraine but
veterans and other british people with
some military experience who feel that
they could
be of help there they've seen the
horrifying pictures on on television
which he said appear to be a war crime
he said they must not go there because
this is not like a two-week sort of
assignment this is you're there until
the end of the war and it is better to
leave that fighting to the ukrainians
with the weaponry that britain has sent
them so a pretty stark message there and
shows a complete split there at the top
of government or were rebuked to what
the foreign secretary said at any rate i
thought it was also fascinating what he
said about the prospects for peace talks
in turkey today pretty high level now
with sergey lavrov the russian foreign
minister there with his ukrainian
counterpart i mean there are some
commentators who say look these
horrifying scenes in mario pole are only
going to spread around the country as
the russian advance tightens its its
grip around he said it was a war crime
he said that britain was going to report
it absolutely but he you know he also
said on whether the ukrainians should
essentially sort of sue for peace now he
said you've got to be very skeptical and
it appears to be not the british
government's advice that president
zielenski should he said reward vladimir
putin's advance on a sovereign country
by making a ceasefire so very much
supporting the ukrainians all the way if
they want to fight on come what may and
i wonder what you thought about
visas and refugees well it sounds as if
that is moving today kay i understand
that the policy is very fluid at the
moment and that um the home secretary
may well announce changes today the sort
of thing um the government are looking
at is whether ukrainians who are here on
temporary visas so people are visiting
students people are working temporarily
but don't have permanent residency
whether they will be able to bring
family members over because they can't
at the moment and that looks like an
obvious avenue for the government to go
down but are they going to get rid of
biometric checks no is what i'm told
even in for children or in special cases
that is not a route they're going to go
down but certainly he sounded very aware
that things need to start moving to
prevent these sort of angry scenes we've
seen at the polish border tomorrow's
take nine and o'clock looking forward to
it thanks very much indeed meantime the
prime minister has continued to resist
calls to drop visa requirements for
ukrainians just hearing there fleeing
the war insisting security checks were
vital uh joined now by eugenie webster
roberta nova chair of the british
ukrainian law association hello to thank
you so much for joining us on the
programme this morning um
what should happen
can you hear me okay no i didn't hear
you
okay can you hear me now
yes i just wanted to ask you your
opinion on what we're hearing from the
british government as far as risa's uh
and biometric checks are
concerned well well we we knew we knew
the cases when investors visas visas for
very rich people were accomplished in a
matter of hours so obviously the uh
security checks are very important but
certainly there are ways to to complete
them faster uh what we're hearing now
that people who were able to escape
the war um are now in uncertainty um
where they go next uh while europe
allows people to come without visas uh
the uk doesn't so basically people who
are exhausted who are retired who had to
flee on on foot who are now in a in a
strange country in a strange city
they have to wait and they don't know
how long they have to wait sometimes
they don't have money to pay for the
accommodation to wait and then the visas
are only issued in a few visa centers um
around europe
really few so this all makes people very
anxious
i'm sure um are you in contact with
people that are still trapped within
ukraine
uh yes i am my whole family is in
ukraine my parents and my sister my
nephew and his family they are in
ukraine
and what are they telling you
well they hope for the better they hope
that um
the uk and the us will help them
we hope they hope that ukraine will get
more modern uh weapons
like fighter jets and air defense system
to protect them from the horrible
bombing
uh
because they go to bed they don't know
if they if they're going to wake up so
they wait for this modern equipment to
be delivered and to stop uh killing
civilians the road is very
risky for them my parents are elderly
they haven't got a car uh they're not
sure they can reach the border
so for them
they're just praying that this stops
yeah i'm sure are you in touch with
people that are at calais at all
uh no i'm not i don't know anyone just
call it
you're aware obviously that there are um
some ukrainian people that are stuck
there not sure what to do next and
others very keen to get into the united
kingdom as and when they can
but it does look as though potentially
hearing there from my colleague tomorrow
that that might
become a little easier from today what
would you say to the british government
first of all thank you so much for your
overwhelming support everyone in ukraine
ukraine is extremely grateful
and the ukrainians are fighting this war
for all of us here
because there is no guarantee that
russia won't move further if it is not
stopped just now so please support uh
ukraine with all military defensive
systems that you can
air defense fighter jets so that people
that civilians
are not killed are not bombed and that
that we can win in this war for all of
us
it's good to talk to you i'm so sorry
that your family is still uh in ukraine
and i hope um that they have um
an opportunity to be reunited with you
very soon thank you very much indeed for
joining us
thank you
thank you sylvia zimchek works as an
immigration advisor for the east london
charity the renewal program and she's
with us now um hello to you sylvia um
again we've we've heard that potentially
the british government might be making
things a little bit easier for um
ukrainians to get into the country later
on today um
up until now how much of a challenge has
it been do you know
well the scheme has been performing very
well
under the uh
um
so under the ukrainian humanitarian um
visa route
there were two schemes uh one hasn't
been implemented yet this was for people
without connection to ukraine without
family in the uk
the other
which is in operation guarantees for
family members of
uk residents
and um
the response has not been adequate to to
the issue at hand
for example um there is not enough
visa processing centers
they have been um
pop-up visa processing centers in in in
poland in in gershof the capacity was
increased in hungary
uh in mordovia
there are talks of additional um
center um very close to color in in
lille
i think people found it very challenging
not only the journey but the process as
a whole um this is um
which is quite complex it starts with
online application which after
submission follows with
booking of the biometric appointment and
then attending
attending the appointment and providing
um facial image and and fingerprints so
people have been turned away from color
and told to go to paris just to comply
with this mandatory requirement
and other challenges with regards to
qualification
where
people lack evidence of their
relationship to uk family members
such as birth certificates marriage
certificates
um
they might even like identity documents
so
they will struggle to to prove their
case um at times especially unmarried
partners and fiances or proposed
propositive partners
uh the other issue um
is with requirement of having to reside
in ukraine prior to first of january
2022
uh
obviously our assumed
people freeing violence freeing their
home country will not think of
collecting the documents as utility
bills from around krsna's period
just to be able to
to prove at some point that they've
lived in ukraine
okay
thank you very much indeed for
explaining that to us and we appreciate
you taking the time hopefully things
will get a little bit easier for
ukrainians trying to come into the
united kingdom um as of today thank you
for taking the time
the show here on sky news the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has told sky
news millions could die if the world
does not act to stop russian bombing
joined by the uk's former permanent
representative to nato that's lord
ricketts hello to you my lord thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning um how would you describe what
happened at the maturity hospital in
mario paul yesterday
well words fail me okay for the horror
of this attack
no modern armed forces should be unaware
of where hospitals are but this
i don't know whether this was deliberate
or in which case it was clearly a war
crime uh or not in which case it was
criminal negligence and incompetence to
strike a target like this indiscriminate
shelling and bombing of civilian areas
is horrific and we saw even worse
horrors overnight
the minister representing the government
this morning saying to us that as far as
he is concerned
the government sees it as a war crime
and we'll be reporting it as such um do
you uh support that
yes absolutely i mean all the evidence
of this should go to the international
criminal court on the face of it it
seems to be clearly a war crime of
course russia is not part of the
jurisdiction of the international
criminal court but anyone involved in
this and all to be pursued for the rest
of their lives for this horror
to compile matters it took place
during a ceasefire humanitarian
corridors that are supposed to be opened
so that civilians can get out of these
bombarded cities they're being shelled
as they try to leave with what they're
standing up in holding the hands of
their children
what if anything can we do
to try to help these people
well i think we all feel uh helpless in
the face of this awful assault
the honest answer in the short term is
we can't stop the russians doing this
kind of
civilian attack okay and we've had a lot
of calls for
air
prevention of any flights um a no-fly
zone but a no-fly zone wouldn't stop
russia shelling the civilian corridors
that they've agreed to i think what we
have to do now is move on from regarding
this as a
conflict between ukraine and russia
confrontation between nato and russia
this is a global issue this is russia
attacking
norms and values of every civilized
country in the world and russia ought to
be a pariah state around the world for
having conducted these sort of
indiscriminate attacks on civilians
across ukraine and i don't think we can
stop it in the short term but we can
make sure russia pays a terrible price
for this for years to come
how concerned should we be how concerned
are you
that
president putin has made failed threats
to other
neighboring countries including
countries like sweden
president putin deals in threats and
menaces and fresh creeping um he was a
spy for most of his life
uh and this that's his stock in trade
i believe that there is a clear
distinction between countries that were
part of the former soviet union where he
seems determined to
bring them back where possible into some
sort of vassal state around russia and
not i think the baltic states because
they're now part of nato and that is an
absolute red line
sweden is also a deeply embedded western
country
it has a duty of solidarity in terms of
all eu members with it so i think that
we should regard this as the kind of
menaces that putin
always returns to he's in a weak
position in ukraine um he's looking for
ways of increasing the pressure on the
west and we shouldn't be spooked by that
we should continue firmly and i'm glad
to see that sweden is very much part of
the western effort to increase the price
for president putin here
we know that he has sent his foreign
minister along with ukrainian foreign
minister um to um turkey to
have um high level the highest level
talks that we've seen between the two
countries so far how hopeful are you
that anything will come of that again
when i spoke to the minister this
morning he wasn't very
no well i'm not either i mean there
doesn't seem to be any common ground
between the two sides at all at the
moment
and if the ukrainians were ever in any
mood for compromise which i don't think
they were um the horrors of the last
fortnight i think have made them even
less so
nobody knows what putin would regard as
a minimum face-saving outcome for this
awful assault that he's now launched but
i don't think having listened to
president zolensky in
parliament two days ago that he is in
any mood for any concessions at all in
terms of giving away parts of ukrainian
territory or conceding russian rights
even over uh the eastern part of the
country so if they can do something
about humanitarian corridors and
civilian humanitarian relief that i
suppose would be good i don't think we
are anywhere near a negotiated
settlement to this crisis okay i think
it's going to be a long crisis i think
the most likely outcome would be some
kind of awful stalemate where neither
side is one but neither side has lost in
any case i don't think that we are going
to be seeing any sort of broken solution
anytime soon
what do you think will happen to the
ukrainian president
well he has emerged as an absolute hero
from this crisis uh i think the entire
country is behind him he's one of those
inspirational leaders that sometimes
emerges in wartime
i hope he's taking great care of his own
safety
and i think you know we should be giving
him all the advice and support we can in
that
it's i think really really important for
ukraine that he continues as the
not just the symbolic head but the
manifestation of their extraordinary
national will to resist
and how worried should we be about
waiving um visas and the security issues
that that might cause in the united
kingdom which is what we're being told
is one of the problems of the log jam of
visa applications
i think we have to put the two parts of
our conversation together i mean we
can't react with horror
at the indiscriminate attacks on
civilians and then immediately turn
around and say we're going to impose an
awful lot of bureaucratic requirements
on those fleeing this terror and making
it extremely difficult for them to come
to this country
the eu are accepting in i think it's now
over 1.5 million people on the basis of
temporary
residence permits
no doubt with checks to come later if
they're still in the eu in some months
time i don't see that there's any
security risk from allowing in women and
children
from ukraine family members
joining others in this country so i
would be inclined to look to waive those
requirements particularly for women and
children and if possible for all
ukrainians perhaps on the basis of a
temporary right to stay for six months
say during which checks could be
undertaken if they want to stay in this
country
look at these pictures as we're speaking
to you my lord these little people with
snow falling they're absolutely freezing
up to two million people have fled the
country they don't know where they're
going to go it's very difficult not to
be emotional about it isn't it
it's difficult not to be emotional about
it and it's difficult not to be saying
to our government you have to do better
to allow those who want to come to this
country who's got families here to make
it possible for them to do so i don't
think we are in normal times where
normal levels of security checks and
biometric checks can be enforced these
people are desperate they're fleeing the
sort of horror we've just seen in mario
paul and we need to find the
humanitarian side of our nature i think
as other european countries are doing to
be a welcoming generous haven for these
poor people all our hearts go out to
them i'm sure this morning
did you think lord ricketts my lord that
that we would see
something like this again in your
lifetime in europe the biggest
movement of people since the second
world war no i really didn't and i spent
40 years as a diplomat trying to
strengthen that set of international
rules which was meant to ensure that
this never happened again they were
brought in after the second world war
which is the last time we saw a horror
on this scale
i lived through the 1990s and the ethnic
cleansing in former yugoslavia which was
terrible but much more limited than this
i really never thought we'd get back to
full-scale war against the civilian
population in a european country it is a
really desperately sad setback to the
darkest days of the 20th century and the
whole world needs to come together to
put the pressure on russia to stop this
awful assault
and a final thought from you my lord if
you will
those that are serving military that are
so
uh overwhelmed by what they see
giving up their posts and going to
ukraine the armed forces minister not at
all happy about that what would you say
well
i wouldn't encourage people to do that i
think we all understand the sense of
incredible exasperation frustration and
wish to do something but remember this
is now a war zone with no laws the
russians are no respecters of the laws
of war um if anyone fell into russian
hands i hate to think what happened to
them i think we should be helping the
ukrainians in every way through material
through from weapons to economic support
through humanitarian support
i would not advise people to go to this
war zone the british government cannot
help anyone who gets into trouble once
they're in ukraine
we appreciate you very much taking the
time to speak to us on the program this
morning my lord thank you
thank you
still to come in the next hour of the
program we'll have more reaction to the
recent developments in ukraine as the
armed forces minister james heapey says
what we're seeing on our television
screens is war crimes by russia in
addition to that he warned british
serving military personnel not to head
to ukraine and in his words have come up
with selfies
he said that they will be in an awful
lot of trouble what does ed miliband
think about that we'll be asking him in
just a moment here on scania
[Music]
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you